this is a production of Cornell
University good morning everybody it's
great to be here and to lead off these
lightning talks and I'm really gonna try
to do this without going through the
whole thing so I want to just share I've
been working on reducing systems for
vegetables for several years and focus
in on both conventional and organic
systems that are suitable for vegetable
crops and margins mom and so when we
look at these systems and evaluate them
we are including many of the goals that
we've already heard about other people's
presentations I just want to highlight a
couple of them that are important to us
climate resilience of course is
important our vegetable crops aren't as
rigorous necessarily in the early part
of the season as some of our agronomic
crops so we have to have really suitable
seed bed so creating systems that allow
for deeper rooting of crops so that they
can acquire soil and nutrients from
deeper in the soil is one of our driving
factors for these reduced systems as
well as to improve infiltration of water
so we can capture retain that water a
year like this it's a reminder another
area so from the environmental side
there's many ways that we try to look at
these systems and again all of those in
line with the soil health goals that
we've talked about already in terms of
the crop productivity we want our
vegetable crops have to be meeting
timely harvest dates and so creating an
environment for rapid crop establishment
and growth are really critical but an
area that we focus in on quite a bit is
on of the improvement in not just soil
health the farmer quality of life and we
think about labor use and labor
efficiency in that how quickly can some
of those early season tasks be completed
to allow that producer or manager to
actually get to other really important
tasks to be timely in the estelle tree
crops and then another major challenge
that we face with reducing tillage and
vegetable crops is weed management so
that comes to be a focus of our work but
we review reduced tillage in a systems
context and what we know is that when we
can stack these different practices and
layer them different soil health
practices that there's an additive
benefit and so reducing tillage or cover
cropping by themselves will help
when we layer that and integrate those
together and add some rotations and
think about other kinds of amendments we
will achieve our cell health goals more
quickly so how do we do that and therein
lies the rub with vegetable crops
because given their sensitivity to
establishment conditions and soil
conditions trying to optimize power crop
growth in a lot of residue on the soil
surface is indirect sort of competition
and contradiction to the conditions we
tend to prefer for vegetables so our
growers very often arm growing cover
crops protecting the soil over the
winter but killing them early and so we
don't get the benefit of the biomass the
carbon additions to soil so what are
novel systems what are new approaches
new equipment that can help us manage
that residue more effectively or improve
the way that we establish our crops in
that kind of residue what are the weed
control strategies or chemical and
non-chemical through cultivation that
can help us achieve that we also know
that you have to be mindful in the case
of vegetables particularly from the
diversity of scale and the diversity of
crop products and so leave worked on
systems that use equipment based
approaches that are large scale using
example like the zoom tool unit here the
zone builder unit um and if we can test
that but then we also have to think
about for smaller farms those that can't
invest in that type of equipment that
don't necessarily have that kind of
horsepower to pull that equipment on
their partner what's a suitable approach
and so we use a reduced tillage strategy
that looks at multiple approaches and
one example in some of our work with
organic farming that we've been doing
recently is really trying to optimize a
mill tale system very small-scale and we
found that using these types of
impermeable tarps that we can actually
prepare a soil bed in the fall and then
use cover cropping or other sorts of
soil mulches and then tarp them in the
spring and it creates a beautiful
condition it deals it warms the soil and
allows us to actually have a no-till
system that can be continued over
multiple years so how do we innovate and
continuously try to integrate practices
over time we've demonstrated that we can
grow vegetables in a reduced Hill system
for numerous crops
are a real objective is how do we then
help growers overcome their concerns
about risk of these systems and adapt
them and so I'd like to be able to just
leave you with a few ideas to sort of
foster some thinking as we go forward in
this day and thinking about this roadmap
I think that we need we need to really
be continuing in vegetable crops of
things about the ways that we do this
stacking integrating and maximizing the
biomass and the benefits of cover crops
in a reduced tilt system then making
sure there's a suitable to large and
small farms using regional type of soil
health experiments or having even on
farms long-term soil health plantings or
fields allows us to create spaces of
innovation and help growers think
together about how do we innovate
innovate these systems creating
incentives for access to some of the
specialized equipment as well as coops
to allow smaller scale operators
actually sharing equipment together how
what are the ways that we can do that
make that work um and we still need
other ways to actually include and
remember and create opportunities for
smaller scale growers to really be able
to look at these systems and integrate
them because we know we can save a lot
of labor and honey and help improve
profitability on those farms finally I
think that's interesting in New York is
we have a really interesting we have
these incentives through something like
the New Yorker and the certified that
includes a EMT or to type assessments
how do we elevate within that the soil
health practice is there and make them
more visible because right now they're
actually buried within the various parts
of the tiers and in some of the
worksheets but create a more
comprehensive vision statement around
that in talking about our New York grown
certified and similarly I think as
mentioned earlier by Pat you know we
have this benefit of really productive
soils how do we prioritize so health
practices and keep on helping think
about our long-term food security
particularly for us and for me and
thinking about that with vegetables
BAM this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu